I live my life a quarter mile at a time
it's better just to talk about i think
the experience in the rods I have a
serious question for you I'm serious
answer VIN and you are the only cast
member of this movie who's also a
producer was questioned it's not just
that the stunts and the cars and the
beautiful women that's a huge reason
that the fans keep coming back action
like you've never seen before adrenaline
like you've done with this brain yes it
was so yeah that was tough as
interesting not what I was expecting we
can play me
how do you keep it interesting for
yourself when you've done so many of
these films then and I mean do we talk
about it a lot and we're scratching our
heads and going what is it really about
we learned from doing the first three
fast and furious that the audience
wanted the film's to connect and to
speak to each other and to grow let me
do the first movie I mean it was like a
small car movie I was doing it over like
summer break so I know really on I think
we're the first one we just got really
lucky we stop the source and we
connected in ways I don't think anybody
even really realize that was cool about
this franchises that you kind of grow
with it and as you know me and Brian
become parents and Dom letting me I
don't want to give anything away I felt
like family tree to feel that love again
it was real we all know that when it
comes to family it could get crazy
stop
but before shooting who was the one
person you were most nervous to me I
think maybe it was thin because like he
please such a strong presence on screen
but he's the bonus human being you could
ever wish to meet that he's such a sweet
man I'm nice to me everybody so what was
it like coming onto this set that's such
an established family and you're coming
in as the village my goal was just to
come in an elevated you go coming subway
right you don't know me tell me with a
bang you have to
this was about honoring Pablo's more
than that its action the drama the
emotions the relationships the family
they should do to be able to give him a
really honorable farewell that's what we
had to do for so we were given the
responsibility of protecting a legacy of
someone that's meant a lot to us it's
really beautiful and I think the fans
will really love it
ah
you